I want to be the guy who listens to my
wife you're never going to finalize that
right because you're doing that all the
time and that's also really useful
because you don't Hit the Target and
then find yourself left with nothing
because you can do that every day I want
to be the guy who listens to my kids and
I want to be the guy who speaks my mind
carefully and judiciously let's use your
example I'm a I want to be a guy who's a
good Steward of my wife that's my
identity and that means I'm going to
have to backfill it with some goals
we're going to meet once a week and I'm
not going to try to fix her like she's a
car engine I'm not gonna try to solve
her problems with her as though she's
infantile I'm gonna just listen and I'm
gonna commit to being quiet and so when
she says I'm really struggling with my
boss at work I'm not going to jump in
with well you know you should probably
tell him I'm just going to listen right
but listen over time I really look
forward to learning more about my wife
and what she's experiencing in this
season and it's different than last
season it's going to be different in the
new season